-Our next guest is a very funny,
Emmy-nominated actor you know
from "Saturday Night Live"
and "According to Jim."
The second season of his show
"Growing Belushi"
airs Wednesday nights
on Discovery.
Let's take a look.
-Neem is a vegetable oil pressed
from the seeds of the neem tree.
It repels up to 600
different types of insects.
♪♪
It has been used in India
for centuries.
It's safe, 100% organic,
and it works just great.
Okay.
Here, you go, ladies.
[ Laughter ]
-Please welcome back to the show
our friend Jim Belushi.
[ Cheering and applause ]
How are you, Jim?
-I'm good, so good.
Nice to see you, Seth.
-You know, I would love,
obviously,
to have you here in person,
but we are making progress.
Last time we talked,
there was no audience,
so at least we have that going
for us this time.
[ Cheering ]
-Well, that's nice. That's nice.
Last time we talked
was last year
and you were the first interview
I did for "Growing Belushi"
and thank you for that.
It was a hit
and this second season,
we started last week
and it's doing great!
-Now, we talked
about that last year,
that you you were sort of
an accidental weed farmer.
[ Laughter ]
This is not something
you had planned for yourself.
Are you getting
the hang of it now?
-You never get the hang of this.
I mean, it is really farming,
Seth.
I mean, this second season
of "Growing Belushi"
is basically about us
redoing the whole farm,
creating new greenhouses,
revamping the soil.
We use the Fohse lights,
LED lights that we use.
So the second season is really
starting all over again.
I mean, it's tuition
in this business, you know?
That's what my cousin says.
I said, "Well, when am I going
to graduate?"
[ Laughter ]
-Is this true, Jim?
I read this -- you still have
never gotten high yourself.
Is this true?
-Oh, no, I microdose.
[ Laughter ]
I do.
I do a little bit
of a Bhang chocolate,
like 2.5 milligrams,
to sleep at night.
I do a little of my Cherry Pie
at the end of the day.
I just do a little bit
to bring the anxiety down
and also to help me sleep,
but I'm not like a stoner.
[ Laughter ]
-But Cherry Pie is one
of your strands we talked about.
Black Diamond.
Are these still popular,
your strains?
-They're very popular.
The Cherry Pie is popular
for couples
because it really
chills you out.
I call it
the marriage counselor.
[ Laughter ]
Black Diamond,
my veterans love
for their spasms that they have,
pain, sleep, PTSD.
And then, last season,
we went down to Columbia
and got these seeds
for Danny Aykroyd,
so I have these
Colombian strains
that we are 90 days
from harvesting.
[ Laughter ]
-That sounds like a Mad Libs,
that you went down to Colombia
to get seeds for Dan Aykroyd.
-Well, he wanted
a legendary seed
to put the Blues Brothers on.
He goes,
[ As Aykroyd ]
Jimmy, it's a legendary brand,
the Blues Brothers.
We need a legendary seed.
[ Laughter ]
I went, "Alright."
-You have some great cameos
this year.
Dan Aykroyd, as you mentioned.
-Danny.
-Guy Fieri.
-Oh.
-Was it fun to hang out?
I mean, obviously,
you know Danny well.
Do you know Guy Fieri well?
-Oh, I've known Guy
for 10 years, easy.
He's just a gentleman and funny.
And he was actually
doing a show.
He was traveling from Seattle
to Santa Rosa
with like three buses of people
and four trucks
with cameras and kitchens
and he goes --
[ As Fieri ]
Hey, Belush!
[ Laughter ]
I'm coming down the 5.
I see your farm's right there.
Can I stop by?
I went, "Sure."
He showed up,
honest to God, Seth,
with 18 cameras and 30 people.
[ Laughter ]
And so we shot us.
I made some Blues Brothers-
infused ice cream for him
[ Laughter ]
and then, he set up my backyard
and set up a whole kitchen.
We made barbecue ribs, clams.
I mean, he was fun to have.
So, anyway, yeah,
he's done the show.
[ Laughter ]
-I will tell you something.
I can't imagine anything better,
if you were stoned
and having a case
of the munchies,
than Guy Fieri pulling up.
[ Laughter ]
It's like three buses
and Guy Fieri.
You'd be like, "Whoa!"
[ Laughter ]
-Well, let's just say
we ate ourselves to sleep.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, we really did eat.
And this ice cream I made,
he really loved.
I showed them how to make
an infused ice cream.
We made Orange Whip, you know,
right out
of "The Blues brothers."
Remember John Candy,
"Orange Whip,
Orange Whip, Orange Whip"?
So, actually, it's right by you.
It's in Massachusetts
this month, it comes out.
-That's very exciting.
Now,
what are some things
you've learned
in your second year
of doing this?
What are some tips
you would tell people
who are trying to embark
on a career
of being a marijuana farmer?
-Don't do it.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Don't do it.
You know what?
They make it seem like
a gold rush, but it is not.
[ Laughter ]
This is farming, Seth.
-Yeah.
-I am a farmer.
I am in the soil.
I am creating, you know,
64° temperature soil,
in order for the micronutrients
to get to the roots correctly.
I need to have
1,100 lumens of light,
so, when the cloud goes over,
drops to 750
and these Fohse lights
go up to compensate,
in order for there to be
consistency.
[ Laughter ]
I've got aphids.
I got squirrels.
I got gophers.
I feel like Elmer Fudd
and Bill Murray in "Caddyshack,"
trying to kill all these pests.
I mean, it is --
The farmer man has a tough life,
let me tell you.
[ Laughter ]
But it's fun. I love it.
-Yeah, well, you can tell.
[ Laughter ]
-No, no. I dig it.
-Jim, you mentioned
that you have some pests.
You have some gophers
and the like.
Do they ever --
When they eat the plants,
can you tell the difference
in the rodent?
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, we start hearing
some Jimi Hendrix
out in the field.
[ Laughter ]
They're all kind of gathered
around the fire, you know,
singing along, you know.
[ Laughter ]
I don't know.
It doesn't kill them,
that's for sure.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, that's, I guess, good?
-Yeah.
-Hey, you also have some time
for some leisure,
despite being a busy farmer.
This is a photo you posted,
I think, on Instagram.
This is you diving
into, I guess,
maybe even the river
behind you there.
[ Laughter ]
-Yes, it is,
right behind me, yeah.
I was, uh,
I was running from fire.
I was being chased by bees.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-I lost a bet.
[ Laughter ]
-I got to say, Jim,
we don't usually have
to pixilate that wide an area,
so, congratulations.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, let me tell you.
-I mean,
congratulations.
-That water was so cold.
-That's usually well
out of the safety zone.
[ Laughter ]
-The water was so cold,
parts of my body changed
since then.
-Well, it's excellent form.
Let me just say,
while we're making jokes here,
that your diving form
is excellent.
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you very much.
-Hey, I want to talk about some
of your charitable work
and I know we discussed
this last time,
but the Last Prisoner project
is something
you're involved with.
Actually, especially now,
that we're living in a world
where we do have, you know,
legal, you know, marijuana farms
farmers like yourself,
you're talking about it
as just agriculture now,
but we have so many people
who are still in prison
for their marijuana.
-Yeah.
Well, they were the pioneers
for the cannabis industry.
They're the ones
that took the arrows.
They're the ones that want
to jail for nonviolent
cannabis crimes,
whether they had,
you know, an ounce
or three pounds on them,
they were trying to make
a living for their family.
And when they get thrown
into prison, it collapses
that family,
creates more trauma.
There are 40,000 men
and women incarcerated
right now for nonviolent
cannabis crimes.
So the Last Prisoner Project,
it was Steve D'Angelo
and Mary Bailey.
We are writing letters
to states.
We've gotten a lot of people
out.
We got Richard DeLisi
out of Florida.
He was in jail for 32 years,
the longest cannabis --
you know, guy incarcerated,
and he's free.
And so it's happening.
It's happening.
The state's attorneys
are the people
that we're really trying to hit
and it's moving along,
but it never stops.
So if you want to write
or donate to
the Last Prisoner Project,
it'll be a good thing
to do for your community
and help these families
come back together.
-Well, congratulations
on your life as a farmer, Jim,
and congratulations on
the second season of the show.
It's always a pleasure
to see you.
-Seth, thank you, and I'll see
you by the beach.
And by the way, congratulations.
You know, you can
grow your own, Seth.
-I can grow my own?
As fast as I would grow it,
my in-laws would smoke it.
[ Laughter ]
Put me out of house and home.
Jim Belushi, everybody.
"Growing Belushi" airs Wednesday
nights at 10 p.m. on Discovery.